I think Earth Day is important...
...because we have to try and work to keep the world beautiful.
You know, with all the machines and all the technology,...
...we kind of forget about nature.
So I think it's important to keep the green things alive,...
...to keep the beautiful things alive.
I love nature.
I love plants.
I love flowers.
They're great and just to help nature out, to help Earth.
I think it's important, firstly,  to give back to your community.
It helps create a better community to be a part of.
If we don't get out into the community, then we're stuck in our own world,...
...and we don't really experience life in college,...
...and we don't really learn as much as we could.
It brings an awareness to people that plants are needed,...
...there's Earth that we live on.
And without that place, we won't be living anywhere else.
So we need to take care of our place and Mother Nature.